I am hypothyroid.
Our proctor muscle tested me on standard process prolybene iodine, 30 milligrams of calcium,
600 micrograms of iodine.
He wants me to take 9 a day.
It scared me that she said no on iodine.
The last week, you said that iodine can flip hypothyroid to Hashimoto's.
My MD said something about iodine stopping estrogen, so she wasn't so concerned about iodine,
but I stopped taking it.
If you want to learn more about that, I have information on the autoimmune course, which
you have access to in the autoimmune course.
I think it's module five that's all about Hashimoto's.
There's multiple studies about people with primary, so there's different Hashimoto's
in somebody with primary hypothyroidism.
Primary hypothyroidism is diagnosed by a person having low T3, low T4, elevated TSH or some
combination.
Thereof, and negative TPO antibodies and negative thyroid globulin antibodies.
If you're listening to me, you go, I don't even know what those are.
I don't think anybody's ever tested me for those.
Then you don't know if you have primary hypothyroidism or if you have Hashimoto's, because the
difference is Hashimoto's patient is going to have a combination of low T3, low T4, elevated
TSH, and they will have either thyroid globulin antibodies elevated or TPO antibodies elevated.
That is the definition of Hashimoto's.
If the person has elevated TPO antibodies and or elevated thyroid antibodies and elevated
T3, elevated T4 and low TSH, that's what's called Graves' disease.
So both Graves' disease and Hashimoto's are an autoimmune thyroid condition.
One is producing an excess thyroid, which can be very dangerous.
One is producing a hypothyroid.
That's Hashimoto's.
By the way, Hashimoto's can actually have episodes of excess thyroid production, excess T3
spill, especially if they eat gluten, which is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
If your primary hypothyroid or Hashimoto's or Graves, you should not be eating gluten at all
because gluten, glianne, protein, and gluten is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So even if you don't have a sensitivity, meaning if you don't have antibodies to gluten, it's
still a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So it can produce an excess disruption of the thyroid gland and issues.
Iodine.
So iodine was the question, oh, thyroid needs iodine in order to make T3 and T4.
Yes, it does, but if you take exogenous iodine, meaning iodine in a supplement, and you
have primary hypothyroid, you don't have Hashimoto's at all.
You don't have antibodies to TPO antibodies, you don't have thyroid gland antibodies.
There's been study after study that show you have almost a hundred percent chance of producing
thyroid gland or TPO antibodies if you take it, if you take iodine for any length of time.
There was one study in Japan that took 354 primary hypothyroid patients.
They did not have TPO or thyroid gland antibodies.
They put them on iodine in every single one of them with a matter of time, Hashimoto's,
or Graves' disease, every single patient.
So iodine was because iodine is a component of T3 back in the 1970s, well, that was discovered
all natural doctors iodine, we could use iodine, we could sell iodine, let's give iodine
to our patients.
They invented these little tests, these IMA drop tests and all this stuff.
And natural doctors started using iodine like crazy.
Well, I think in many doctors that really understand this, I think that it is actually del-right
malpractice, we give everybody iodine, this is just wrong, it's very wrong, and it's very
dangerous.
That is why we have one of the reasons why we have an epidemic of Hashimoto's and Graves'
disease in this country is the use of exogenous iodine from well-mean doctors, but have not
gotten to adapt and read the studies.
There's even books on everybody needs iodine.
Okay, did you just got to be careful about some of the stuff that it's just not correct?
So I'm not opposed to a person taking iodine when they've diagnosed with breast cancer if
they don't have any thyroid issues.
But the reason is that iodine is, the thyroid is just hungry for that mineral.
So it will, iodine just literally triggers the thyroid and it can trigger an immune attack
of the thyroid and that's how you end up producing antibodies to the thyroid because you're basically
triggering an immune attack to the thyroid.
So that's my story, and I go into greater detail in the autoimmune course on iodine, it's
just not the right thing to do.
And if you never did a full thyroid profile, or let's say you did years ago, you should do
that again, and again, that's a full thyroid profile, what we call this take is doing T3, T4,
or free T3, free T4, or at least one of those sets.
TSH, reverse T3, viral globulin antibodies and TPO antibodies.
So looking at reverse T3 is important too.
And certainly, if you're not running the antibody test, which even some thyroid doctors don't
do that.
So it's just, I don't get it.